MARTIN OMANDER: Li Na
sent me a question--
how do I authenticate calls
to my Cloud Run service?
Well, it depends.
One, if your service
is a web or mobile app
backend and you need
to validate the user,
use Firebase
Authentication, send the JWT
token from your
client, and validate it
in your Cloud Run service.
Two, if your service
is a backend,
but you don't want to validate
the JWT token in your code,
consider API Gateway.
Three, if your
service should only
be reachable from other services
in your Google Cloud project,
set Ingress to allow
internal traffic only.
Four, if your
service should only
be reachable from
other services, which
may run outside Google
Cloud, download a key file
from Google Cloud and set
Require Authentication.
Five, if your
service should only
be reachable by people
in your organization,
set up a load balancer, Identity
Aware Proxy, and set Ingress
accordingly.
What are your Google Cloud
Serverless questions?
Post them in the comments.